congrats on the movie uh I laughed a lot
and I wanted to stress the word a lot
um uh but I am curious uh are you
surprised for both of you are you
surprised a little bit that you got cast
because I heard you had to be in the
Americans the TV show to get into this
movie yeah yeah exactly
oh yeah no I knew from the jump uh once
I got the call from Elizabeth it's
because I put out a tweet when uh when
they announced that she got the rights
to cocaine bear I put out a tweet praise
in the movie before they had even you
know got into production and once I got
the call they're like hey Elizabeth
Banks I wants you to be in cocaine bear
I knew it the the Stars had a line I'm
going
serious um it's very rare in after a
hundred years over 100 Years of movie
making for there to be like a movie that
I've never seen before you know and this
is that movie
um when you first heard about her you
know when you got the script and uh when
you like get the F out of here when you
were reading what you wanted to do in
this thing yeah I mean from the very
beginning that's always been what's so
exciting about it it's different you
know like especially a big Studio Movie
that's not based on something you've
heard of before that's a new idea that
says crazy and zany as it is and I think
that's one of the things people are
already kind of responding to like I've
never been a part of something that
wasn't sort of already a thing that
people knew about like a year and a half
ago people would be like oh yeah I've
heard about cocaine bear because you
hear the title it's so weird and then
the movie is you know really lives up to
that fun zany kind of audacious
Adventure that it is who's on your shirt
oh uh you know the room yeah Tommy Tommy
oh hi Mark yeah
no but the thing is I also wasn't even
sure if like even like maybe 20 years
ago I don't know if you could do a title
cocaine bear you know like I the fact
that they're the title is actually
cocaine Bear yeah it's like crazy yeah
totally yeah dude all day I'm tripping
off the fact that we're doing interviews
but like CNN right yeah yeah Morning
News yeah they're like so cocaine Bear
right talk about this bear on coke
completely so the movie has some [__]
sorry for the language some great pills
that are bloody and funny and you know
uh unexpected for both of you which was
your did you have a favorite kill or is
there a kill that you're most looking
forward to audiences seeing I wait for
the premiere so I haven't seen it yet
but I know from reading
that that last one should be something
something to see yeah I think the last
one's a pretty big one yeah that one's
pretty big
I'm excited I didn't give it away but
some gnarly stuff when the bear is on
screen it uh uh audiences when I saw it
people were very very happy I'll say it
like that all right for sure good
see you guys worked with Isaiah how long
before you asked him to say [__]
he uh funny story the rap gift that he
gives you is actually a bobble head of
him saying
she wow yeah I didn't get one so it's
all right bro it's a black thing but
yeah he loved it oh he was such a great
dude utmost professional he was great he
gave this speech when he wrapped yeah
that was just like crying yeah like the
whole time we're just like damn I'll
never be an actor like Isaiah
he's just uh the the dope is dude man I
can't wait to see him again listen you
guys got to work with Ray Liotta I was a
huge fan of Ray's work I'm not trying to
bring the interview down or anything but
like can you talk a little bit about
working with him because I mean he he
was he's fantastic in this but he was
just a fantastic actor yeah it was such
an honor to be able to to get to work
with him and I'm so glad that that I did
I mean he was so fantastic when we were
just doing the scenes he's you can feel
that he just had this enormous power and
and it's one thing to see that as a fan
on screen but it's another thing to
actually be in the scenes with them it
was really great that this was like a
movie that it seemed like he was having
a ball making you know and and he really
he had a lot of fun so um he'll be very
missed yeah they didn't really get along
yeah
no but so it was uh it was a it's an
honor you know I didn't get into acting
I I didn't want to be an actor you know
I just kind of had the perfect storm to
make this job work and you know since 20
12 I've just been trying to make it work
and when you're able to work with the
Giants in this industry like Ray Liotta
it's just a a gift that you didn't know
that you needed and it's uh you know
it's it's terrible that we won't be able
to you know party with them at the
premiere or or those type things but we
hope uh we are honored that we get to be
in his his one of his last works and uh
we know that he would have been thrilled
with how crazy our movie turned out I
actually have an individual question for
each of you um what can you tease people
about den of Thieves too because I know
you start shooting soon and also Swagger
season two and Alden can you talk a
little bit about
um you get to be an iron heart and you
work got to work with Nolan on
Oppenheimer which is yeah I mean it's
kind of cool um can you can you please
talk about those things Swire season two
uh will be out out in June
um we uh you know the kids are older so
it's just going to be bigger and better
as far as the basketball there's um
there's a lot of things happening
between
Jace and and Ike this year uh because he
you know he's starting to be a man on
his own going into high school then
going into college he's not on you know
the AAU anymore so it's a you know it's
a it's a nice Dynamic to be able to be
able to do with my man Isaiah Hill and
then yeah dinner thieves too we're
getting ready to go they got me uh
training and on my regimen every day and
I told them that after this one after
how much they're kicking my ass I'm
going straight to animation baby nothing
but video games and cartoons for about
half a decade kiss my ass
my answer's not gonna be as exciting as
that
um uh yeah just super cool ironheart I
can't talk about it very much but it was
a great great great experience and I
love the people who were making it and I
think it's a really cool
um new chapter a new world within the
MCU and then Oppenheimer was you know
what I live for which is like working
with great film directors it was just a
[__] unbelievable experience and and
I worked mostly with Downey so that was
right before I did ironhearts that was
really fun because I got to talk to him
about that and uh
um that's gonna be a great movie
I'm very confident on on that note
gentlemen congratulations on the movie
and I wish you guys but the best thank
you so much good to see you you have a
great ass day Steve